to be together too
Kim Kardashian's daughter Northwest
shows off her baking skills whatever she
wants to do when she is old enough she
can do the mother-daughter Duo's latest
Tick Tock features them making treats
for Easter Sunday Kim being Kim rocking
a bikini for the occasion
thank you
it's always so much fun at one point
North ditches her sous chef to make
cookies on her own but little sister
Chicago eventually joins in on the fun
for me
North's final product and Easter
Masterpiece I don't know what's gonna
top that but fans who followed the pair
on Tick Tock know northie is a cooking
Queen it's really fun to see in fact
Selena Gomez's younger sister Gracie
recently joined North to make homemade
pasta yeah super impressive to watch the
BFFs make noodles from scratch all right
now we have to move on to the next step
listen to me more egg because look at
this oh my gosh
okay time for egg that's an egg
oh my goodness North even guides her
younger siblings through some of her
recipes making a milkshake
[Music]
oh
my house is so full but in the best way
it's it's amazingly full I'm making my
smoothie okay what are you putting in
dragon fruit
everyone gets along everyone loves each
other I'm rolling with it it's just it
is really Zen it feels really equal and
calm and great we can't wait to see what
North's next excellent creation will be
always
[Music]
foreign